sancerre est situé sur un nom qui domine
la vallée de la loire yvan m'a organisé
une pause déjeuner sur les berges
sauvages du plus grand fleuve de france
une visite au fil de l'eau pour
découvrir une nature exceptionnelle
en plus d'être une nature exceptionnelle
c'est surtout le dernier fleuve sauvage
d'europe ça tu viens d'entendre de grand
plouf devant là c'est certainement un un
petit boudera qui vient de plonger à
rats mais vivant quand mon âge de la
nuit les rails des dommages avec nous
c'est comment la
ici c'est tonton terrain de jeu favori
tu le connais par coeur méité merveille
toujours autant tous les jours qu'on
écoute je la connais jamais parker faut
jamais dire ça parce qu'elles changent
tous les jours tous les jours le petit
grain de sable se déplace à des petits
bras de loire qui s'ouvre d'autres qui
se renferme ce qu'on appelle la
végétalisation et wall e le fait qu'elle
soit pas du tout entretenu par l'homme
depuis maintenant quelques années de
plus 76 on a vécu sur la loire on a une
nature sauvage mais en même temps il a
préservé sa rien paradoxe intéressant là
dedans complètement faut gérer les flux
les les gens qui pêchent les gens qui
chassent aussi mettre tous les
utilisateurs en en harmonie alors
souvent ils vont tu parles 12h odeur de
goudron c'est l'odeur des castors c'est
ça le dorat souvent on n'y fait pas
attention mais quand il ya un peu
d'humidité dans l'air tu sens la
propolis des peupliers des saules et
quand tu sens le goudron un peu la bouse
de vache c'est le cast of vient gratter
avec ses pattes arrière est un muscle
qu'il a sur une glande derrière la queue
pas du tout un excrément ses couleurs un
peu rougeâtre unsa sans cette odeur
l'impôt si je voulais un peu rigoler
avec toi je prends une brindille je t'en
colle dans les cheveux tu sens le castor
pendant quinze jours dans mes cheveux
semble qu'à toi pendant trois mois et
jusqu en galère vraiment chaude au caire
il ya des gens qui viennent du zimbabwe
pour pour
bivouac est ici pourrait profiter des
dieux et il était contraint de se
baigner parce qu'au zimbabwe se baigne
pas si facilement parce que nous on n'a
rien de dangereux dans l'eau c'est un
des derniers territoires et si on veut
le garder ou tu peux tu vois si on veut
planter notre tante en dehors de la
réserve on peut dormir là et si tout le
monde fait ça à un moment donné on va
perdre ce côté là donc faudrait juste
qu'on gère un petit peu mieux ça et en
france on vit un peu trop sur nos acquis
on a des gens qui prennent soin de la
nature mais pas suffisamment et toi
regarde top tu vois le petit chevalier
guignette qui parle on appelle ça un
club lensois un cube blanc au kenya
n'est pas le même que moi du co2 dit
j'ai touché un peu la flotte là on a
combien de degrés saint là on est à 25
aujourd'hui tu vas aller pas encore trop
trop chaud de 25 elle monte à 30 quand
elle est vraiment très chaud pour
l'espace d'un instant tu m'a pas dit
qu'ils avaient des sirènes raya de
sirène elle va le tirer de là bas celui
des sirènes tu compare souvent la loire
à des fleuves africains
cas pas les crocos c'est un fleuve
sablonneux tour on parle du niger j'ai
beaucoup de gens qu'on voyage et qui ont
la chance de le faire à l'époque et ce
côté des placements de sa bande sable
oiseaux tu vois oiseaux les oiseaux
blancs les aigrettes qu'on pourrait
comparer des pics des africains tu vois
quand tu regardes évidemment c'est pas
la même végétation mais et robinier faux
acacia tu pourrais imaginer les espèces
de longues ou des paysages un petit peu
toi l'afrique avec les girafes pour
imaginer c'est un peu chez nous on à
sancerre quand même alors on va quand
même parler des produits locaux à écoute
ça va avec la nature on n'a pas
l'impression ici parce qu'on est dans un
paysage mais tu fais un petit saut de
puce juste sur notre gauche on à
sancerre à droite puis une grande faille
calcaire sous l'eau fait cela et on a un
petit confetti qui est connu dans le
monde entier qui est le vignoble de
sancerre chaque bille ont fait un ou
deux blancs différents jeux temps mené
une petite bouteille de sancerre ont
deux petits verres et on va se poser sur
un bout d'île et on va déguster ça situe
au niveau
des gares de pas de salir les pieds à
léo plus loin une équipe au plus cinq
aventuriers aux aventuriers garde un
petit bleu crémeux un petit fermier un
petit blanc qui est sûre du calcaire un
petit verre de vin ça lui met un petit
barbecue avec une basse côte marine et
de boeuf donc puis je vais te faire
caraméliser ça dans un papier d'alu on
va ce goûter des bons 28 regardez ça
fait vraiment plaisir est ce que tu as
vu beaucoup de monde autour de sa
personne